我們朱老師做了哪些功課
才能變成K線之神呢
今天要來全揭秘喔
盤中的幾個
四大觀察的重點
數據指標韓國跟各國
8點45 9點開盤
對
大概到10點 10點半
然後在收盤前
這個小子也很重要
那如果你今天看
那就小心一點
今天大概
應該跌不值100點
朱老師會提供一個
他每天做功課的獨家表格
我叫做裹票日子
也要做個簡單結論
戰備表有沒有準
我預估台股第二天會向障
那慢慢的你也可以做分析師了
老師上次我們是紅綠配
對
這次要藍綠對決
還好我今天沒穿綠的
不然就要撞山了
要撞山了
不過上次我們有一集有提到
我想把老師綁在桌子旁邊
就引起網友有些人還抗議
對 他們覺得
這是不是趙華優是一個什麼黃段子
其實沒有
這就是每一個
認識朱老師的渴望嘛對不對
因為我們在做那個
現土的時候
希羅老師沒有在旁邊
像教練一樣叮嚀
很快就忘了啊
是啊
對啊
所以大家對你很依賴啊
不會啊
大家要自己自立自強
但是也有人利用這個
學員對你的依賴喔
聽說現在市面上有很多人
用你的名義在做假群組
招攬人家進去
不曉得做一些什麼
一起去幹麼收費或什麼
這還蠻可怕的
對啊
所以大家還是在網路上
還是要小心一點
各位可以看嘛
用我的名稱
然後用我的大頭貼
還用我的照片去做訓練班
可是這些看起來
我無法分辨的
對啊 如果你看訓練班
就知道在收費上課嘛
對 這很清楚 但很容易就會上當
所以一定要再沾著去確認
你看他結的圖 這都是我的獎益
有上過我同學的課
有上過我課的同學應該一看就知道
這都是我上課的獎益
所以像這樣子的行為
我還是呼籲一下
就是同學自己要小心
可是我要怎麼分辨
因為他用你的大頭照
他也用跟你群組一樣的名字
那什麼才會是真的
我們要用什麼政治標記來找
那我個人現在
因為我上課的時間也很忙
所以我有一個專任的
一個助理林寅老師
所有的群組裡面的處理的大小事
都是林寅老師的
所以我們這邊有林寅老師的Line
你可以跟他直接聯絡
你可以先問一下
我看到了一個群組在招生
這是真的還是假的
你可以跟他本人做
那我個人的一些FB群組的大頭像
大概就是這樣
所以絕對跟剛才那個是不一樣
因為他去拉了別的照片做大頭照
所以應該有兩個方法
一個就是直接這邊有把老師
算是助理的Line
李英老師的Line放在這裡
有興趣的可以把它抄一下
再本來問我們李台當然秀
我們一定不會騙他們
對
稍微就是沒辦法這種事情
據我知道也有別的老師
也遇到同樣的事情
所以我也是呼籲大家
好 今天的理財大連秀
大家最期待的單元叫做
標古在線等
我們的朱家宏老師又來囉
那我們影片的一開始
要很宇宙心常地說
因為今年股市非常的熱
成交量也非常的高
那我們知道有很多的民師
或者像我們請來的達人
是非常受到大家的信賴跟喜歡
可是房間也會有很多的不孝份子
知道老師現在
非常受到玩偶的信任
假借老師的名義
用老師的頭像
老師群組名稱在招攬會員
其實這是很可怕的
所以剛剛朱家昊老師有說
他有個助理叫林寅老師
剛剛有公布他的Line ID
如果覺得有質疑有懷疑
或者想要加入的話
請找林寅老師
或者是
你也可以問李才達人秀
因為李才達人秀是佛心正派經營
一定會給你最正確的答案
那今天我們要來做什麼呢
很多人在看完我們上兩集
教你做當充
其實很多人會想要知道說
除了做當中
老師到底一整天
怎麼樣從台股1700多檔股票裡面
找到屬於它
不管是短線或長線操作的標的
那到底盤前 盤中 盤後
我們朱老師做了哪些功課
才能變成K線之神呢
今天要來全揭秘
老師一整天在做什麼
我們先來看一下
我這一天20小時除了睡覺
大概都在忙
對啦 大概都在忙啦
那當然我個人事情比較多
但是同學你要把股票做好
有些工作是一定要做的
那要 而且還要持之以恆
要每天 對
如果你看了以後
做了三天就沒有用了
你講到99.9%人了
我提供參考
因為每個人的生活不一樣
每個人也許你還要上班
你要趕得對 不可能的
我還要上課
那我講一下我的工作啦
我大概6點半以前會起床
有的時候會早一點
有的時候6點或者6點半
我也4耶
對
我大概8點以前就會進工作室
所以主導是一個工作室
大概8點以前會進去
8點鐘以前我就會到工作室
到工作室以後做什麼事
因為期貨8點45開盤
所以在期貨之前
要去看一些期貨
我們等一下就會講準備的事情
好不好
那9點就開始看盤
這邊就在看盤了
大概我們的大盤各位也會有個感覺
大概到11點到12點半就很平淡
小無聊
又沒什麼行情
你看了到半天也不怎麼動對不對
那這段時間對我來說
可能就會用一個簡單的用餐
那我中午盡量都會小睡一下
因為我到底不像同學這麼年輕
早上又起來的比較早
我們也想睡只是沒辦法
對
所以我都盡量
能夠睡我都會去休息
當然有時候忙也沒辦法睡
在盤中
我們今天最重要就是
開盤前要做什麼
對
然後這個盤中要做什麼
然後1.45收盤
這個這個是最重要的
是
然後最後當然
因為我下午或晚上
我都會有一些課
實體課要上
對
那另外我還有一些雜事
當然啦
我們對不對
還有家庭什麼的
要去爭培
我們每週三有三次的大盤分析
那這個當然要利用盤後的時間
然後還有就是節目錄影
還有我們每個禮拜要約會一次
對 這個最重要
累了一個禮拜
這個約會一次就
保持年輕的心情
好 這個大概是我一天
其實有三大塊
一個就是盤前
再來就是盤中
盤中的話老師覺得
12點半到1點半重要
那當然大家比較好奇的是老師盤後還在做什麼
我們幾個重點
早上就是8點45 9點開盤
大概到10點10點半
這段最重要
然後中間休息
然後在收盤前
這個小時也很重要
對 今天大概的結果都快出來了
你大致上也要準備一些事情
所以老師你8點到工作室之後
你會做哪些功課
我們來看一下
我們就從8點開始
8點鐘這個時間
黃金6小時
對
趙華在拚收視率
老師在拚報酬率
不過我先講
這個不是我的工作室
沒有這麼豪華
背景背景
這個太豪華了
那我的工作室跟大家講很小
不要以為老師是很大的派頭
我的工作室很小
兩瓶都不到
大概只有一瓶多
兩張桌子三台電腦
是
四個畫面
就是這樣
我想只要有人做進去就可以
所以基本配備其實這樣夠了對不對
對足夠了啦
因為最重要就是我們剛剛講
這些資料怎麼準備
盤中怎麼去看
這些才是最重要
所以盤前我們要做什麼呢
盤前的一小時囉
因為我們8點進去嘛
如果你做股票的大概9點開盤
所以有一個小時
那這個小時你要做的事情
其實蠻多的
各位要把握這個時間
但我也先說明
你今天看覺得說
哇 怎麼這麼多東西啊
那我又講你耐心一點
你慢慢做
大概半年之後你就很快了
得心應收
你就每天都看的觀察嘛
好 要做哪些事呢
第一個我們先看昨天的台股的收盤
那如果這個你昨天
下午有空晚上有空
你已經做了
那早上當然你就輕鬆多了
那就看昨天的台股來看
然後最重要你今天要做
所以你要知道今天會漲會跌
是 這個我們在前幾堂課
其實有教過大家怎麼看K線
對 你就知道它趨勢方向K線變化
還有昨天有沒有放量
那還有一些指標嘛
我們也教過MACDKD
等一下我沒有範例告訴你
你為什麼會知道這些
那第二個當然就是一些籌碼
但這些籌碼是大盤的 不是個股的
大盤的籌碼
那大盤當然最重要三大法人
三大法人
三大法人像各位看
外資這三四天都在買
雖然說沒有很驚人的數量
但是至少他連續在買
站在買方
那融資融券你也可以去看
還有外資的借券
法人的期貨
那這些其實在各位的軟體都有
你可以慢慢的去
去詢問 去研究
然後外資的選擇權的
布局的方向
那我今天等一下
也有提供一個表格
你看了這些剛剛開始的人
可能你看了就忘了
所以你列一個表格
你把它寫上去
而且你是用寫的
所以你一定有印象
等一下朱老師會提供一個
他每天做功課的獨家表格
如果你用手寫跟朱老師一樣
你比較容易學起來
我們等一下會來揭曉
所以前兩件事是這樣子
那後面還有第三件事
當然這個是要早上看
因為你要看每一股收盤
都是盤前一小時要做完的事情
像今天早上你去看美股大概在平盤附近
那我在說明中有講過
美股如果開在平盤附近
對我們今天的開盤是沒有影響的
除非它超過兩%了
像前幾天大漲2%大跌2%就會影響
然後再來最重要的是看韓國
上次有講韓國其實跟我們CC相關
跟我們的聯動性很密切
而且又提早開盤
對 它又8點
我們就看
等到我們8點40
你就注意一下
韓國今天到底什麼狀況
決定有沒有做修正
最重要是修正
因為你昨天看台股
看這些你覺得今天應該很好
可是早上一看
美股也跌韓國也跌
那你今天可能就沒有辦法
照你預期的這麼樂觀
所以你開盤叫謹慎一點
不要馬上就衝進去
所以這個是讓你做一些修正的
然後最後一個就是
最後重要當然
還是你手上的股票
我已經預計好今天盤
大致上會怎麼走了
然後就來看我手上
假設你手上有三檔股票
這三檔的狀況怎麼樣
是如何
對 你手上的是最重要
如果今天你手上股票
要出現變化
你是不是要賣
這個停利最重要
所以你就開始再看一下
因為你三支股票
昨天會有變化
其實主導師這個還滿重要的
很多人可能自己手上10股
股都還沒有準備說你要擬定策略
你就開始看新的
其實手上可能疊得稀花
你都沒出力
還有同學手上有什麼股票也不知道
都不知道
他也不知道他手上有什麼股票
太可怕了
對
那你稍微檢視
所以我也跟大家講過
手上不要太多
你不要一二十檔股票
大概你真的不知道
你有什麼股票
最多幾檔
最多三到五檔
一般的資金
再大一點也不要超過十檔
大概七八檔股票這樣子
你比較好控制
那你都準備好你今天的有沒有動作
那還有一個就是你的鎖股
對
什麼叫鎖股
因為我們在前面的節目有跟大家講
你收盤以後看強勢股
強勢股你可能找到了一些好股票
就我們已經把它
你列入我們的資訊觀察的
觀察鎖股的水庫裡面
那可能你鎖股的股票
今天有一兩檔可能要發動了
所以你這一兩檔就請你今天
特別開盤去注意一下
如果他發動
那就是你的好機會
先把手中的持骨看一下策略
然後把鎖定的個骨
看一下開盤後的狀態
先這樣子做
對 才來得及嘛
你都想好了
盤中大概應該就很充容了
他如果沒什麼變化
你也不要緊張 再去找新的
OK啦 好
所以先把這四件事
在盤前一小時做好
一小時做不完就做兩小時
因為老實說大概半年後
你可以跟老師一樣的功力
我個人來講
這是我個人的座右銘
我個人的座右銘大概
大概大家都知道
第一個一定是技術分析
性技術分析
也就是說我剛剛前面所有的研判
各位有發現都是以技術分析為本的
然後第二個是等
等
等機會才進場
那我看這個股票好
今天沒有發動我還是不會進
我一定要等他確認
是 因為這樣你的勝率才高嘛
對不對 你確認了七八成
應該可以抓到他的勝率
那最後當然 手
你繼續分析
你又等到機會
那後面就要有機率了
所以剛剛有講
其實老師呢
盤前功課做完之後
就開始用手寫一個神秘的表格
今天帶到現場
什麼樣神秘表格咧
這裡自己設計的嗎
對 這個是我叫做股票日子
你自己設計的啊
我個人來講的話
同學要是願意的話也很簡單
那我可以把這個電子檔給我們的製作單位
可以
等於如果要就善善爛
反應他就好了
那我們是沒有賴群組
可以到我們的粉絲團
Facebook
他就自己到影印店去
把它輸出影印
糟糕了
我們要被訊息傳爆了
因為這個黑白
黑白的嘛
魚城臉現在在發白
那我個人的意思就這樣子
我個人是每三個月訂一本
三個月
那你就自己去訂一本
到營店訂一本
因為你這個每天要用
一整本這樣的表格
這個日子裡面有幾個很重要的內容
第一個日期就不用講
你一定要今天
這個大事記也很重要
這個大事記比如說發生了
什麼大事
甚至於今天美股大跌
你都可以寫到這
或者川普又有什麼新的動作
這些你都可以寫
但是當然是要跟股票有關的
其他的就不用
不要寫在這個地方
是大盤的大師還是個股的大師呢
沒有股票的大師
我們股市的大師
股市
例如說今天台一店的ADR大漲了
7%那我可以寫嗎
可以啊
還有最重要還是一些
騎腳所的政策
這些政府的信的政策
彎經經經常囉
會開會囉或什麼的
或者今天
幾月開始可以做股票當沖
開放當沖對不對
這些
那因為我們人嘛很忙
你時間久了
你前面一定忘了
忘光了
對 你已經忘了
所以這個可以讓你要回去犯月
好
那這些就是我們剛剛講的數據
昨天的大盤 昨天的期貨
那再來就是均線
因為均線你每天寫
就會發現它的變化
是
我們有講均線它的排列
對不對
所以這也是大盤的還是個股
大盤的大盤
我們現在都講大盤
都講大盤
對
那這就是我們的買賣超
我們剛剛有講
要去看三大法人的買賣超
那如果寫你就有印象
他是買超還是買超
然後他有融資融卷
那還有就是這個期貨單
三大法人的期貨單
先練習寫這個
對
對數字有感覺
其實很多人可能
問你昨天外資買賣多少
沒印象了
投信買賣多少
其實都不行這樣
甚至收盤收多少
有人也望光光
記得寫這個功課
去寫一寫練練功
練練功好不好
好
那這邊就是早上囉
早上看美股囉
美股是大指數
倒窮啦
那斯達克啦
他的收盤
然後他漲幾點
然後最重要就是百分比
你漲了百分之多少
對
那這邊是早上
這是昨天的韓國
對
昨天韓國收盤
那我在這邊提醒一下
大家不是只有超速
是
這個寫完了把它圖打開看一看
圖打開看一看
長別的原因了解一下
哪些類股在長嘛
那你去看它怎麼長的
到底昨天是特斯拉在拉
還是蘋果在疊
要了解一下
這個大概
那下面這個是鹿骨
還有一些歐洲骨
老師我這張寫完超過一小時了
開盤了
那你可以這邊提早
昨天先寫
因為這個到晚上這些資料都有了
你就可以花個20分鐘 30分鐘先寫
總之老師都會做這些功課
大家反正時間不夠就往前提
對不對
就是把功課做完就對了
後面這個就是你手上股票
立上去
那我這邊是10檔
就是希望你不要超過10檔
再多你沒地方寫了
再多我就要寫5個小時
假如你有3檔股票
那你這個股票當然你當初買的成本
一定要知道嘛
還有你有多少張
然後你這停損價在哪裡
這個庭裡是你的預估
我預估會長到哪
這樣好不好
好 除了這一張之外呢
老師還有一張啊
沒有 我們一天正反兩面嘛
正面反面
那這個就是戰備了
這是你早上剛才寫的那些
請你做一個簡單的結論
你看了法人買賣鈔
你看了盜窮的漲跌
那你這邊趕快
我寫結論心得報告
不對
真的不能照燒就對了
這個好處就是
我今天寫了一個結論
可能今天會
小長四五十點
那你收盤看看
你寫得準不準
這樣子你寫一寫
你就會有心得囉
你看到那一本
我今天說要長五十點
不是是疊一百點
然後就發現每天都很不準
對 那就是你可能
再去加強一點
那慢慢的你也可以做
這個分析師了
我可以考個分析師
你可以大盤分析師
我那麼準我就去考了
那這你我講
這個就是早上要看美股的稻穹
稻穹長多少
那這就韓國了
8點40 8點42分
你去記一下
那這就有關開盤了
那開盤我們有講5分K
5分10分這些
那這個我再強調了
你在盤中開盤大概沒有時間寫
對 這個沒關係
老師說到我新生了
5分鐘我都還沒有下單
這個是你事後去寫
好然後大概你每天的交易啊
這個功夫下去
我希望大家
我個人從學股票一直寫到今天
寫了十年
對
我十年前還認識你嗎
對啊
就是寫情書寫了十年
情書哪來
我要看你寫的
檢驗一下老師親密寫的
老師不要叫大家寫
結果你自己沒寫
不會
對 老師寫在哪裡
好 老師給我的情書
我們來看一下
這是我個人的
我個人大概折錄了一下
真的有寫
這是星期一的大盤
星期一的期貨
9月15號寫的
這個是9月15號寫的
這個是9月14號的
我是9月15號要做股票
要操作
你看指標KD的方向
這個大概都有記錄
那均線
現在你看到20均還在往下
對不對
可是你看外資是買的
買超
自營買超
中資也在增加
那就是主力也買 散戶也買
大家都在買股票
OK
那這個就是期貨單
外資
當然這個沒有什麼太大的動作
大概還有29000多
老師我抓到Bug了
你沒有寫大四季
因為昨天沒什麼大四季
不行
今天有寫
今天要約會
今天會寫大四季
對
好 那這是昨天早上的盜球
昨天早上的盜球
那昨天早上盜球你看長1.18%
那我們也有跟大家講
盜球在1.5或2%以下
跟我們沒有影響
沒有影響
那最後你要做個簡單結論
讚倍表有沒有準
就是簡單結論
台股紅可以長100多點
是昨天 對
前一天的
突破6天的高點
突破軍械
這個綠柱還有KD都向上
所以我預估台股第二天就是這一天
會向上
但是向上9月3號有個高點
這邊會有壓力
所以昨天大概到這裡就下來了
哎呀
節目等一下音色像畫面好不好
對
所以陳嬌亮縮小
因為他前一天的這個量是縮的
陳嬌亮縮小
那可能還是一個區間震盪盤
這是指昨天
昨天是一個群天
那美股到窮漲不會影響
那8.40韓國在平盤附近
所以我們期貨大概也在平盤附近
好 所以9月15號
就昨天
那現在我們進入到開盤了
活生生血淋淋要來應證這些事情
對不對
所以開盤後老師會做些什麼事情
現在早上準備工作
進入到盤中囉
要開始開盤囉
那開盤我們最重要是看盤中的幾個
四大觀察重點
數據指標韓國跟各國
剛剛有特別講大盤
指標的走勢
韓國很重要
還有我們鎖定的各國
我們在開盤的時候
所以各位
大盤要看什麼呢
就位的畫面也要做好一些設計
設計
第一個我們先看看大盤的預估量
像今天我們錄影的
今天大盤就放量
我們今天有放量
昨天是亮鎖
今天放量然後拉台積電
拉台積電 預估量
這個我們上次講了外盤價
昨天的外盤價還是比較多
內外盤的話
大家可以去看上一集的標準在現等
高水內外盤的意義是什麼
那這裡還有一個
我們在盤中要注意
這個上漲加跟下跌加的比例
那如果你的上漲加
是下跌加數字的兩倍
紅的是綠的兩倍
你今天這個大盤不會跌的
他一定是維持紅的
好 那開始的時候你會發現
這兩個差不多 對
但是你會發現紅隊越來越多
那就表示 買盤一直進來
買盤表強
那這個我們上次也有提到
盤中的一些直升壓力的鑽力
對 我們再來教這條
你就可以知道今天那盤好不好
好 下次來教直升壓力
然後再來呢 指標股是什麼呢
指標股有三大塊
第一個當然我們叫做電子股
電子的全直股對不對
這個叫金融股
金融的全直股
然後這個叫台塑室吧
原物料的全植骨
傳產原物料
那這怎麼看呢
假如我今天是想做多的
你做當從也一樣嘛
你如果今天想做多
那你盤中如果這個都是紅的
你今天就比較有力
今天全植都長的話
大盤也不會過啦
對 你大概就比較有力好不好
所以我們分成三大類的全植骨
來觀察
那這三大類有不同的特性
電植骨主攻
也就像今天大盤要漲
一定是台積電 兩發科要漲
半導體 對
那金融股主手
存股概念 電子連走了三天
可能要休息了
那就換金融股來撐盤
那這樣子你今天
就很容易再繼續往上走
那如果你今天看電子綠的
金融也綠的
那你小心一點
今天大概應該跌不止100點
不過前一陣子有一段時間是
傳產原物料很好
對 那這個都是撐盤
好 身材而已喔
要工還是要科技
要工要電視過
然後再來剛剛一直強調韓國
這個我想大家應該都記起來了
韓國先開盤喔
韓國會8點開盤
然後你就 各位也複習一下
我們前兩集啊
這是不是開高
開高KK是什麼
強弱盤
強弱盤會先回來
那他回來剛好我們大概就是8點45了
快9點
期貨要開盤囉
對 然後你就看到韓國
他真的很標準
他已經過高
回後買上漲韓國就走了
他就走多了
所以台股也樂觀了
那盤中你也去注意
他是不是在走多
對不對
盤中他一直在走多
他是我們的領頭羊
對
好 進入到個股的走勢囉
是老師觀察的個股
或者你們手上觀察的個股
個股就是
我剛剛有講你手上
鎖股嘛
假說你昨天晚上看
我鎖的這支
鎖定這支
我鎖的股票已經盤了五天了
而且是不是在月線上
是
月線有支撐
然後多頭回檔沒有破滴
那如果他今天攻的話
那是不是我叫進場
我今天是我買點
那在這邊
無迫他的整理了
所以今天是最容易攻的
所以你盤中稍微的盯著
對你別的先不要
別的股票不要管
你就盯到他
那如果他今天開高的話
我們又複習一下
這是5分K
開高非K
不能動
你是開高非K
黑K不要進去妄動
但是你又知道我開高
把昨天這個高點過
所以我開高是多頭
是
是多頭
但你不能做
所以你要等第二根
第二根是紅的
非常OK吧
但是你這個紅的這裡有個壓
看到沒有
很簡單
有人在這邊被套了
對 你只剩壓力
這個壓化解一公來了
這就上當無壓力了
他就來了
對不對
所以你看你去把這個
五分K我們教你的這些技巧
你用在你今天想要進場
你想要買嘛 今天是旗帳嘛
那先證明他旗帳
再證明他上帳
再證明他把這個壓過了
那均線一定很好
所以你就可以在這邊買
你在這裡就可以先進
老師但是我在這邊買
並不見得是為了做當沖
沒錯
也可以做波段
你可以做當沖
波段是因為今天是旗帳
所以你可以留
如果今天第三天你就不能留了
這樣好不好
所以他這邊也有配合啦
例如說他突破的時候他放量
對
還有一個很重要
我們剛剛有講
盤中支撐壓力
各位知道這個壓力
在電腦上去點就有65.07
這邊是壓
我的這根紅K的收盤各位看多少
65.06嗎
對 65.06
等於什麼
所以基本上我的收盤
我這邊的收盤就剛好過了
這邊的壓力
所以你進場很好
剛好壓力過了
所以你就很容易就會漲
是 然後這邊的KD值
也算是有一個小的黃金交叉在這邊
這個是多頭牌列
多頭牌列
KD多頭牌列
所以很符合你進場
又是一個多頭
然後均線也是多牌的狀態
沒錯
所以你是不是成功
全部都燙到在上面了
都很高
這是你今天要鎖的股票
是
如果你手上沒有股票
當然你就去看大盤的變化
好 然後老師
因為我們還是一樣回到
選股要凝聚
所以剛剛有講到
例如說有些題材的類股
好像前陣子風電太陽那樣
不如我說傳產原物料很好
他可能一走整個類股會走一個大波端
所以題材面老師會不會稍微關注
那我一直跟他講
我們做股票
除了你用特別報價去找
找比較強的股票
那你平常也要注意一些
看看報紙
還是要看新聞囉
對 這一定的
因為你是專業
你要在這個類行裡面
所以第一個注意科技
因為我們講科技永遠都是股票的主流
你的美股也一樣
對
它永遠都是
所以你要去知道科技未來的發展
大家都經常聽到5G AI 電動車
還有一些安控設備
大概這些跑不掉的
在未來三到五年 甚至於十年
像AI智慧大概都要很久
電動車也越來越成熟
可能都要開始淘汰
開始太患了
所以它等於這個市占率會越來越多
然後再來還有一個就是
我記得有一個老師
他就專門講看報紙賺不票
看報紙就可以賺錢
應該不是骨魚啦
我忘了
你要正評還是裂評
要告訴我
我才知道我要端誰出來
對不對
所以你看
如果你報紙有發生一些天災人禍的
供趨時條
你叫反向思考
我們很多事情要敏感
反向思考
像前一陣子的疫情
你就趕快想
這個疫情防疫概念啊
口罩概念啊
對 會有什麼東西
遠距教學啊
也就是什麼東西對它有利嘛
對不對
當然大家都想到害處
實際上一定有得利的
所以你要去看一些供需試調
那比如說現在很多天災啊
水災啊
那這些玩意要不要重建
水水的類股不要忘了
水泥啊這些銀件啊
這些天災越厲害
他們的後面的商機越大
越大 越大
這個就是一種這個需求的
供需的關係
那第三個當然
我們就技術分析來講
你就可以在盤後的特別股去找
找這個強勢股
好 所以我們有題材
我們要注意像這種新聞類的
就是可能天災人或其他
有意外的傷疾
最後當然還是從我們的報價強勢股
量放大股這些技術指標來看
你慢慢的有這些敏感度
你就越來越容易抓到方向
好 我累了一早上
我盤錢做了工作
盤中看完盤
現在我收盤了
是不是還要做功課
輕鬆一點
我收盤了 我現在要做什麼
回正空虛
粉絲都很關心我的休閒活動
私生活 狗仔現在要出動了
收盤了 朱老師在幹嘛
完了完了我的
曝光了
私人機密都要破光了
老師的隱私
等等
老師年紀也不輕啦
打手遊好像年輕青少年
你搞錯了 你搞錯了
我們在打手遊的時候
你們年輕人都還沒打了
怎麼可能
你問
我在明
我們在很早的時候
就在打了個小精靈
那不是手遊嗎
那應該是機台吧
那是大的機台
因為那個時候只有那個啊
就在開始打啊
不行 我不能聽過
我沒聽過 什麼是小精靈
你沒有聽過
所以就有打
那現在當然就在手機上
手機玩什麼 攤食舌嗎
這是一個什麼
這是一個紓壓
也是活化一下腦力
好幾年前就打那個憤怒鳥
憤怒鳥
你跟俞辰的新智年齡一樣
因為做得不好
就去拼命打了
好 這個是其實可以紓壓了
還有你在做捷運什麼
你就可以稍微休息一下
放鬆嘛 一天都很緊張
第二個吃大餐
那這個我的優勢就不怕胖
其實我還有一個很大的時候
就是逛街 逛街 逛什麼
你看我的衣服不夠漂亮
很漂亮 都新的
都飽和色
都跟我在PK
要配上也很難的
不會 老師可以
老師已經取得入場券了
所以看來收盤後
你的心沒有刮在股市
你開開心心
逛街吃飯外送店
夠累了
而且我也講理用技術分析
你晚上睡覺也很安穩
也不要擔心你手上的股票
隔天早上起來再說
對 你昨天早上做一些準備工作
你手股票擔心對不對
那你就趕快你的股票今天要做什麼
所以老師今天如目春風的
尊尊教會有沒有讓你覺得很溫暖
其實老師真的不常思
然後給你的丁尼一定要放在心上
那今天我們的公開版就到這裡了
再來老師會到菁英斑教你一個更進階的
什麼呢 剛老師其實有提示
你是不是買了很多股票
老師有講嗎
開盤你要先處理手上的股票
可是可能很多人買了以後有沒有
堆成那個股票的水庫你都沒在管
所以今天的金銀斑會來教大家
如何檢視你手中的這個股票水庫
幫你太弱流強
但是在金銀斑進行之前我們要先來感謝
這些加入我們金銀斑的網友給我們的鼓勵
這個應該叫Lentis
他很喜歡朱老師
他說你循循善用生動的教學讓我收益良多
每次看都有新的收穫
他就想說趙華以前號稱
東森觀之林
我要強調一件事
觀之林比我老很多
我後來就覺得
是個可敬的前輩
所以現在隨著理財
當然就受人歡迎人氣飆高
看來應該是觀之林
要改教香江里趙華了
I love you
非常有創意
好 Jason說
朱老師教的每一集都前行一動
是我聽過最棒的教學
謝謝老師也謝謝
趙華我當散戶代表
我常常都裝傻裝呆
你們有發現嗎
沒有啦 本來就很呆啦
然後另外這一個
MAVERICK應該叫什麼 RIK
好 謝謝朱老師
他說因為
喜歡朱老師的加入的精英班
他希望有招募一日成為高高手
相信所有看理財達人秀的朋友們
你都會成為高高手喔
所以今天非常謝謝朱老師
公開他一日行程
不怕狗仔跟蹤
那朱老師有講他一個禮拜
最開心的時候就是跟趙華見面喔
這個時候狗仔來偷拍我沒有意見啦
剛剛有講了有很多的戒律
有很多盤前盤中要做的功課
不要忽略
半年後試著寫寫看老師提供的這個手稿
寫個半年
看你會不會變成真正跟朱老師一樣的
禮貸大人投資高手
我們禮貸大人秀下次再見了
Bye Bye
字幕製作人Zither Harp